[Music]
fred has been so generous with his time
and with his work and literally there
are hundreds of Fred lines photos that
are showing on the screens here tonight
we've got them for those watching on
video or livestream we've been showing
them on four screens around the room
through the course of the night the one
you'll see some of the ones you've seen
before in this presentation and some
that you haven't as well and and then
we're gonna show even more afterwards
Fred's books are for sale in the back we
hope that you'll buy one young artists
need their support right so so it's
important up-and-coming artists before
we get into the conversation with Fred I
have a little well first of all I want
to say as you may have noticed Otto our
chalkboard robot drew a map of San
Francisco this map is adapted from it's
actually a couple Maps smooshed together
at a very old map from the 19th century
and a more modern map so that it gives
us the bones to talk about the city as
we go through some places in it the
David Rumsey map collection makes an
appearance here and this is a the
historical map that's one of our sources
and thanks to Cameron from our team for
helping Auto draw this tonight but the
very first thing before we get into the
conversation is I've put together a
little something with some of the the
photos that that I like the most from
the large set that Fred shared with us
and I want to just sort of say a few
things over it so this is 85 photos in
365 seconds that I've put together for
you and it's going to let us just dive
straight into the work and like I said
I'm gonna just say a couple things over
it to hopefully introduce some of the
themes we're gonna go into tonight is
that is that good Fred you want to say
anything before I launch into that yes
lock the doors don't let
this is your life Fred lion okay so here
we go and Fred lion and San Francisco
are two subjects of the night so we'll
start with these eighty-five photos in
365 seconds and we talked about this
how how photography is really all about
time so I'm gonna say a few words and
stir up the themes these postcards from
the past some icons from today's San
Francisco you'll recognize other things
that hint at an age gone by there's
nature and culture and art and commerce
intermingled in a San Francisco we all
know well it was a night like this long
ago let's have a look maybe even gawk
the frame shows the scenes that are old
but maybe new to us while others are
familiar persistent and enduring the
present decontextualized by seeing it
also existed in the past sometimes a
dramatic new vantage point or the same
again enduring change that stays the
same
but difference cities are like this
stable but dynamic still but in motion
like what we call pace layers here long
now culture in nature up against each
other an entangling of governance and
infrastructure and commerce all those
parts moving in concert and contrast
some things fleeting never to return
others continuous the persistence sets
though costumes may change with fashion
steps on the temporal path to where we
are now even though we're in the same
place all alone but there are odd
artifacts in the midst some are surreal
or real but still strange others seem
banal which makes their details
irrefutable the photos remind us there's
a story to the moment and to each face
and more stories every car connects
lives transit an open window travel
between places between stories stories
frozen in a moment or a trajectory how
did the moment end what happened next
where are they now around the block or
the world
maybe the surreal meeting of the end
meeting the ordinary is actually always
present the iconic object under
maintenance Golden Gate Park Splore II
framed as a sliver beside the fact of
all our humanity a front yard rare in
San Francisco with an unnatural glow
strange things maybe from before you
came to town did you hear about that
accordion house who's this guy there's a
story behind each picture making to
practice choices luck and timing in a
sense we're all in the currents of time
rushing past in youth changing pace as
life goes on our memory is biased two
big occasions so we may miss how sweet
an everyday moment actually is just
another day at work the same old commute
home sweet home
each moment every day open to routine or
epic adventure a photos not worth a
thousand words it's different sublime
the photo brings feelings in between
words so I'll stop the words and just
give you Fred's photos for a little
longer
85 photos in 365 seconds we made it
wait Liam thanks everybody have a great
night and and we end with four iconic
San Francisco shots
these are Fred's skinnies do you wanna
maybe we can you can say a quick word
about skinnies then we'll go back into
the actually it was a an art director
who was working on a new magazine a long
time ago and he had columns vertical
columns he had to fill and he said do
you have any skinny pictures and he said
I said why I said well I have a client
who has some very bad copy and I thought
if we if we put if we put a large
picture instead of the bad copy would
get away and so I you know these are
just crop beans and I thought hey this
is fun and I kind of like the look of
them and that's a sort of an elegant
proportion and it was a great success
and so I've been making them ever since
it's just a cropping but San Francisco
is a very vertical town mm-hmm and so
why not do vertical pictures it also
encouraged me encouraged me they make a
lot of vertical pictures because I
discovered early on when I was really
starving and needed to I was being paid
by page rate and I discovered that if I
shot horizontals the best I could hope
for was a half page but if I shot
vertical I might get a full page
and so I really learned to shoe the
market it's the practical advice we get
from you that is okay so I want to say a
couple quick words about tonight there's
a lot to potentially fit in I've put in
more than we can possibly see and that's
okay we're gonna cut we're gonna get as
far as we can with this and we're gonna
open it up to questions from you I've
got a nice little setup here so that I
can jump back to earlier photos it may
take a little bit of hunting but if you
see a photo that you want to ask a
question about later try and remember
what it is if you ask
hopefully Fred can speak to it and I can
also find it in here so just something
to think about
we're also going to have the photos
going afterwards and yeah so anything
else I should say well so so this is uh
this is our our hero a few weeks back I
want to say a quick thank you to to Gary
Aries a gentleman holding a camera right
back there and and he has been the
photographer for the majority of the
events that we've done here and for long
now seminars as well and a great friend
as well and and it was he had he met up
with Fred I guess maybe last year at an
event that you were were at and came and
said there's this photographer San
Francisco native in societies I'm like
is that Fred Lyon and yeah but but Gary
not only recommended but but but helped
to to connect us for this I'm so happy
that it's been searched a joy working on
and this is one of Gary's photos from a
studio visit he did with him I knew
about Fred because of this awesome
documentary which KQED the local PBS
station did it's on amazon prime for a
couple bucks you can watch at fred lion
living through the lens I highly
recommend it it's probably probably
maybe 10 years ago now something like
that that it was done something we're in
that area and but it's great so we're
not gonna repeat anything with that so
anything you just make sure you see that
- don't don't repeat any of the same
stories okay
that's a terrible thing to ask anybody
we don't get along that's our biggest
problem so so let's let's take it back
so so we're gonna we're going to start
with your your your first encountering
of San Francisco tell us a little bit
you're your fourth generation San
Franciscan tell us about your people as
they say what were your folks and and
well that was a lot up down the
peninsula huh uh-huh first in San Carlos
and then then in Burlingame but my
family's always been here and we're
still here we're there were there other
photographers and your family or other
artists or somebody turned up a
wonderful picture of my father with a
very strange-looking thing taking a
picture and that was the first that I
knew about it but at the time when you
had to look in the camera and and line
up two little circles in a little prism
and that was not photography really so
you were born in 1924
I was his birthday was last week by the
way
so it's really more like he's 93 to be
honest you know but but no but but
really 94 ya yard yeah really actually
next week there's going to be the fall
Antiques Show it over here in Fort Mason
and I will be represented there oh yeah
they'd like to have me because I'm their
poster boy not to be clear not venue an
auntie did but not yes not the but your
photographs it's not that you're the
antique it's that your photographs are
there by your your photos video okay all
right well clear that up later so so I
have to ask so as we've talked about
this it's it's about you know we we all
lived through time you have have had
this relationship with the city the
entire life including documenting it in
this way and you when you were born
there were no bridges to San Francisco
and and so the the bridges start
construction I think both in 1933 and
are completed over the course of three
or four years what I only imagined that
that was world-shaking misconception on
it but I don't know as a kid what are
you what perception you had about
bridges yeah actually it's it's rather
odd living this long because I was here
before the Embarcadero Freeway and I'm
here I think we won on that one yeah
maybe he'll be around when they build
another embark it's right that's right
but San Francisco somebody asked me
didn't I miss the old San Francisco sure
I missed that
but that isn't what this is town is
about this is the town that is a vibrant
evolving
metropolitan area and it has
to evolve and it has to change and
there's some things that I don't care
for I could do with a lot less traffic
and I could certainly do with better
parking but we have things that we
didn't even dream up I love to eat and
the food in this town
offers us such incredible variety and
only time has brought that to us and the
cocktails are still pretty good the
cocktails are are superb so so on that
note here's a vibrant evolving
Metropolitan gentleman in the in the
peak of his where I don't know if it's
the the peak in the thriving part of his
hair yeah so let's let's talk about your
your career and you you had you joined
the Army is that in the Navy the Navy
sorry I was going to save the world and
well that's still here so it didn't
quite work out but but you were pilot
briefly is that to fly yeah carrier
planes and that never occurred uh-huh
but at one point I got out of that and
they sent me to off to Washington DC and
there I was in a very tiny photo unit
and that in the Navy Department so you
had already taken up photography before
the Navy I had well when I thought of
when I was finishing high school I went
to started down at Art Center okay and I
was there for a little while and that
was the mixed arrangement they weren't
sure what to do with me and they
threatened me and they felt threatened
by me
well but but we had a wonderful time and
then I went to the Navy and in the Navy
I covered the White House and
subsequently that changed a lot of my
picture values because up until then I
thought that the slick advertising
things worthy really what I wanted to do
but I worked with news photographers
there and that really changed my picture
values mm-hmm and then when I escaped
from the Navy are you on the run still
do we need to well I was a you know they
give you some mustering out pay and so I
took that and went to New York for the
Liggett Ori drunk and that went on for a
while and I walk in New York I don't
yeah when that got to be a little thin I
was people kept saying well what are you
doing I said well I'm I'm trying to see
what the photography market is here in
New York I didn't know what that I was
saying but a couple of people gave me a
little slips of paper with somebody they
knew hmm
and one of them was a was a fashion
studio and by mistake I got a job as a
fashion photographer hmm and I didn't
really know anything about fashion
photography but I was very young and
very brash mhm and they offered me real
money and so I said just let me close up
my apartment and I'll be here on Monday
and it was just that kind of a time when
everybody could reinvent themselves and
I just kept backing into good thing yeah
and what a win about is that you're wise
are we talking oh that was in the early
for bid for cash and then you came out
so you did that for a few years I I
can't
out here after doing that for a little
bit I felt that there was something to
photograph that wasn't exactly 8 to 10
feet away from me and so when I came out
here I came really to visit my family
and they would do my laundry for me and
then there their friends kept saying
well Frederic
what are you doing now and I would say
oh I'm I'm going to be a magazine
photographer I had no idea what that was
or how one became it but I kept saying
it and one day the phone rang and it was
a call from New York and it was a
magazine and they said we understand
your magazine and that was that was the
beginning of a large downward slide and
there were just so many opportunities
and I was the only thing I'll say in my
own defense with it
I was willing to grab every opportunity
and kick the hell out but I just knew
that if I didn't there were a lot of
people who wanted that same opportunity
but there was so much variety and I did
everything I even photographed the dog
once so now a dog photographer
specialized the dog right and mixed
right many thousands of dollars there
there aren't just ahead of the career
there aren't just food photographers
there are people that only do entrees
and things like that yeah so eventually
I did everything yeah I I did do food I
did do fashion I did underwater aerials
anything that came by but it was it was
all just it was all really about the
exuberance of the time because everybody
had been deprived for the years of the
war and everybody just felt like they
were running around with their shoes off
and they were willing to take chances on
things and that really is where we all
got excited because we could experiment
and once in a while somebody would take
one of our experiments and do something
great with it sure it made me look good
being 3,000 miles away from where
publishing of curry if something didn't
work out they couldn't get at me so I
think they just didn't know what I what
I had missed so let's I want to dig into
this little because it's fascinating
there's an interesting little conundrum
of the fact that all the photos we're
seeing tonight I want to talk about the
photos we can't see so all the photos in
that you shot for life or you were
shooting for life and for Vogue
regularly is that right and but those
are not photos you actually have copies
of you know we I I spent a lot of time
driving to the San Francisco Airport
directly from my shoes sometimes in the
middle of the night to go to what was
air express at that time the Railway
Express agency and putting them in huge
red envelopes and when he says them he
means it used to be these physical
things that you shot photographs on so
well so you would have rolls and rolls
of film that you just exposed film yeah
and I would never see them again yeah
because it was like dropping him into a
bottomless pit but that didn't matter
because because the editors kept calling
we were on to the next thing done it was
so much work it was so much work it was
a time when I was really booking
everything every day solid and I had to
quit doing that because sometimes I
would find myself going out to a shoot
without having thought about it which
was you could get away with it once
but you could get away with it so so now
we're in the 1940s and you're a regular
photographer one of the the main
photographers for for life I was having
a lovely yeah I bet I got away with
murder but one something that's
fascinating is we've talked about this
San Francisco was another planet it
seems like to to New York so you were
kind of you you you had editors that
didn't know what they were asking for it
seemed like seem like you were kind of
bringing them what what sales go was of
course I was I was trying to keep the
wolf from the door right and I would
call editors with story ideas and they'd
say well you know they felt it was all
cowboys and Indians out here and they'd
say what do you got out there I'd say oh
that's easy
we've got steep hills and fog a couple
of bridges that won't quit and we've got
hurricane and and they say okay I guess
you can shoot us a story on that and so
I'd call her and say well we got to go
do it again both unattached was at that
time and we liked we liked jazz and so
we would go to the clubs and herb knew
all the ladies and that was nifty
you're just so innocent that's nifty
thanks her I just had to experience
everything it was part of my job
literally but you know photographing
this town is really a shock because
anywhere you point the camera you come
up looking good yeah
and everybody was was very receptive
there were some exceptions
maybe I loved working with the kids on
the street and now that's what I miss
these days because there aren't many
kids playing in the street parents can't
afford to live here and and I don't know
there just aren't many kids but it was
all a product of the time everybody was
eager the only exceptions I found were I
once intercepted a a telex from an
editor in New York who sit and fred will
capture pictures of the aw on the face
of the chinese in the background in
Chinatown and I said no no let me get to
that telex I said Fred will not capture
all on the faces of the Chinese in
Chinatown they will be the most
impassive expressions that one can
imagine but that was not any reason to
stay away from Chinatown you know the
neighborhood's were delirious yeah
Chinatown South of Market North Beach
was was just right well we'll we'll take
a look at that a second I want to do
this one bit of the publishing world
coming together this historical photo
for a second and then we'll dive into
some more of your work so so this is
1953 1953 I had a call from Wayne Miller
Wayne Miller was a marvelous
photographer
and he and John Redis and I were doing
99% of the San Francisco assignment work
and he Wayne and and his wife Joan had
Wayne had been part of psychons unit in
the Navy and Wayne and Joan helped
Steichen put together and edit the
family of man exhibition which was
incredible and and Wayne called me on
the phone and said Fred Steichen is
coming out for the for the first time to
the west coast and everybody wants to
meet him
no that's ridiculous that's just not
possible so I've invited we're having an
afternoon with Steichen and everybody
all of photographers on the west coast
are invited and all the photographers on
the west coast and we want you to 90 VIP
we want you to photograph this and I
said with all those guys those heavy
hitters why me he said well I want to be
sure that we have something on film and
that was a backhanded compliment didn't
speak to my creativity or separation but
I was a good plotter and so this was a
marvelous day everybody showed up in
fact I still look at the close-ups in
this picture and there are people their
faces I recognize and I'm still trying
to identify them so but we can say so
this is there's a lie working up there
Dorothea Lange Dorothea Lange is in the
center and sorry well I'm sorry
no it's and Steichen sitting next to her
and this is Cunningham is up on the up
that's Joan right there right your
hostess
and then you had it on a timer I assume
because like somebody else somebody are
you armed down here and get in and so I
crept in over here on the left way on
the left but it was it was a incredible
gathering I don't think you could ever
put together that kind of a group
together again so we're taking it at
Wayne's Wayne Miller's home in Orinda oh
yeah yeah and and it's still there and
it's a family still lives there so we're
gonna go through some some sets of
photos about particular projects and
this about aspects iconic aspects of San
Francisco anyone who wants to guess what
this first section is what if this is
this is the photographer's friend fog is
so important it's it is our identifying
natural effect but it's very you know it
it covers up works of band that need
covering up and and then there are a few
things that you can actually manipulate
and use for your own usefulness and
unfortunately it's it's not something
actually there somebody now makes a
little a little bug bomb a fog that you
can you can use I have the real thing I
have one but I haven't ever used it it
probably doesn't work anymore this is
out not far from where yeah we have a
four point beer on back there that's
looking into the sunset
you think that they're near burger there
there's a there is a little backstory to
this I was doing it for some magazine a
story on San Francisco and I had had a
phone call that morning from the
magazine and they said Fred we're trying
to close this story but we don't have
the fog pictured yet did you promise I
said look you can't cue the fog just
when they need it I'll get it to you
soon
I said well if it doesn't get here we'll
have to do the story without it and that
evening my bride and I were invited
upstairs to our landlord who was
upstairs it was funny or us a cocktail
and when I was up there he was just
about to pour and I looked out the
window and I could see this string of
fog coming and we lived in Sausalito at
the time and I said oh don't pour her
ready and I said I promise you a bio
drink the moment we finished taking this
picture but we have to go right now
and so we rushed out there that's just
above where Sutro Baths was and that is
my landlord and my bride and my uncle's
car
and while it looks very romantic if
they're I'm so glad there is no
recording of Fred for Chrysler take the
picture Beijing are bums and we're dying
of thirst
just one more exposure as I had to take
them immediately to the nearest bar very
expensive production nobody made that
you made your deadline
and actually we didn't print it again
for another 50 60 years but but now it's
in the book
no it's in the book but we'll get to the
book in a minute okay so so then there's
this guy mr. herb kane so so do you
remember when so so herb kane just to
get our our facts right here I think he
started in the 30s writing for first in
Sacramento in here is that sound right
he was in Sacramento yeah and he was
known as the sacrament a kid and he
appeared here and was an instant success
and herb was unique in that he really
got San Francisco and did a column that
was like no other and nobody has really
been a success and trying to do that
again was always irritated people who
said well herb what are you gonna write
something serious and to me this was a
great accomplishment it I mean there
it's it's hard to explain to someone in
a way it's like you know when there were
three networks and everybody watched
Walter Cronkite and that kind of thing
but for San Francisco there was
hurricane I don't know that most cities
ever even had so much kind of a singular
voice that kind of represented the city
in that way it was is that what you
would say from being hot
brainsick you know I would say that was
true yeah and he really loved it and and
he was so let's let's just characterize
it for folks who never saw it cuz but
first of all for 60 years basically he
was writing for The Chronicle and
briefly for the examiner in the midst of
a yeah and that there were times when I
would be going through my cleaning my
desk and I would find it a snap that I'd
done of him and I would throw it in the
mail to him and once at a party he said
hey Fredo would you do me a great favor
I assure her of what she please don't
send me any more pictures he went
through a period when he had electric
hair as it did everything and then then
he went through a period when he didn't
have enough hair but he was he was out
on the town all the time and when he
went when he went to the examiner
I asked his replacement at the cron how
it was try to write it herbes king
hurricanes column for the cron and he
said it's no hope there are only so many
talking lawyers and talking doctors in
this town and herbs got them all sewed
up but sir herb wood herb had a a roll
of three by five cards there were a
perforated roll and they were in his his
trusty royal and whenever the phone
would ring he or his assistant would
take whatever came in and if it sounded
like something promising they would type
it on that and it would go into a little
card file and when it came time to put
together a column
herb would go through that and and
rephrase it you know three dot
journalism as he called and and and so
just and we can't fully characterize
here but but and he started in the 30s
he was writing until the 90s he was
doing six a day six a week rather six
days a week and then ultimately down to
three but they were these little in a
way it's like a string it's like a
Twitter thread of little little little
chunks of things as you said the sort of
index cards together and it's things
that are happening tips or gossip a
little bit here in there
how would you characterize what well he
was actually writing there were
wonderful little squibs that he had
adjusted to to make them really sing
mm-hmm and you know if you were if you
fed stuff to him regularly every once in
a while he would mention your name and
that was a great thing and I found that
my UPS man would always ask me when he
came to the door how was your buddy herb
[Laughter]
everybody does read this and and I did
get to know him through a number of
wives so we're gonna make a transition
in the music scene and here's another
familiar face
who will get back to but these are just
amazing photos so let's talk about jazz
and the jazz scene what you were you
going out to the Jazz and how many have
there what were the jazz clubs that were
happening and well how would you go
about well film hitting the club on
street was was very rakish
totally unrecognizable today but we're
marvelous Jazz era I was in a different
club every night and I assumed that this
was going to go on forever all the jazz
greats were available and I couldn't
conceive of a world when they wouldn't
be in place some of these are well some
of them some of the pictures were from
assignments but some of them were just
because I was there actually as time
when I thought I was there why didn't I
shoot that then there is the the idea
that maybe I was there but I was too
drunk actually it actually it wasn't
easy to get drunk because there was
usually a two-drink minimum and the
drinks were just off they were I want
him I want to give a great
of work so you you were going out no
matter what it sounds like but there
were assignments was there interest in
the jazz scene from the publications oh
yeah yeah yes and well there were
certain people
these guys were marvelous this is myth
Milan the trombone and Marcy Spanier
Bugsy I had known in New York but he
came out here and retired to Sausalito
and I I have to say I would in our in
his latter days I would run into him in
the post office all the time but he
never wanted to talk about jazz he just
wanted to talk about baseball
but jazz scene was non-stop and we had
good clubs that were painfully smoky and
and the booze was terrible
now here for instance this this is a guy
Erroll garner Aragon yeah
who was known for his piano and an
occasional grunt in the middle of it and
this is probably the only good picture
I've ever seen of him and I've loved it
but it looked a little bit a little bit
mechanical so I I tried to do something
else and this is one of the experimental
things were you doing this just for your
for yourself or was it something that
was published somewhere or well some
other thing but some of the things were
for ourselves we did do a there was a
magazine called posh that was published
by the piano orient lie
and they had an inspired editor who has
been with us up until very recently and
he had an idea that we should do it a
jazz story but because they wanted to
position this magazine for all the
different ports of call that they had
they said we can't let's make it
abstract let me talk about jazz but
let's not let's not really show exactly
who it is oh and that's and that's that
photoshoot so we'll look at that's the
one other first mile I always get this
up who was a great chronicler of North
Beach who had recently had three books
and was I had many adventures with him
but we didn't cruises together and lots
of jazz lots lots of good food wine all
sorts of marvelous things and he did
something that I I have to say I have
envy he had a marvelous he had a book
his third book signing I had a debut in
North Beach and everybody came and
everybody ate and drank and he had a
wonderful time and he died the next day
whose his diary F birthday well and I
was so envious of that you know
going out in style is really important
really important and he had a lot of
style
do you want to say something about Billy
we've got a few photos when you took of
course OE the faithful always appear no
matter when these were for a couple of
different shoes I think but one of them
I think was at the bar Mark Hopkins and
we were all there at one o'clock because
that was the time that she could come
because she just got out of the slammer
for a drug charge and but she was there
and she was marvelous so and this was
Sonny Rollins and Sonny is still with us
and he's my hero
this was part of that shoot that we did
with Ernie where it had to be a little
abstract and nobody was publishing
abstract pictures of those days but
Ernie did and was one of the things
we've always loved and it it looks
better today than it did them and Fred
likes this photo so much that he sent
both the black and white on the color
version of it so that I could choose but
I also could not choose that's one of
the great things that's happened to us
these days is that that we're able to
we're not able to do so well on color
from black and white but we're doing
able to do really marvelous black and
white Coleman so now this so so I asked
Fred so who's the guy playing the hairy
parched looking instruments and Fred
said that's Harry parch
that's what it's like talking to Fred I
was living in I was living in Sausalito
and my studio was down in the a little
shipyard and the old shipyard had lots
of space and so starving artists work
sort of camping out there and somebody
said to me did you ever beat Harry and I
said who's Harry he said well he's he's
the brother of that of virgil parts the
cartoonist that's in that new yorker all
in time i said well what's what's he
doing here
did you know he's invented some kind of
crazy music it's a 24 tone to the octave
scale I don't know but but he's he's and
he's composed this music to go with it
but he's had to invent instruments that
are different in order to play this
music and I thought well if he's here in
town
and he's our own personal whatsit I
better go see what he's doing and so I
went and he was a fascinating man who
was just hanging out
barely subsisting but building these
incredible instruments giant marimbas
that were really impressive when when
you'd hit a note on it it would it would
make the floor birds floorboards really
vibrate and and there was something
about the music that was captivating so
he had he had a lot of time on his hands
and so whenever I had time we'd do a few
more pictures and eventually people
began to pay attention to him and he did
a lot of compositions he did a few Rico
and eventually there was a there were
some performances of large costume
productions on the Sausalito waterfront
against the background and it was very
dramatic
not many people understood it but a lot
of the people were were captivated by it
and he went on to have a great cult
following and big influence on Tom Waits
all kinds of experimental composers as
well and and you said does go on and you
said you did a jazz shoot she was some
jazz musicians pretty much right after
that right and you told them about Harry
well I went to a concert one night
because Stan Kenton was in town and I
went backstage afterwards and here's a
picture of the back of stands head and
so you basically drag them over that the
day after this to be Mary and this is
the drummer shall we shall we have
Charlie man Tony man yeah and I was
telling them about about Harry Park and
they said gee could we meet him sure
let's go over tomorrow
and so they came to Sausalito and here
is Harry giving them a demonstration or
a a pep talk and they were they were
fascinated and
shellye even experimented on the giant
marimba so we're gonna skip ahead we're
getting a little Evan time Joe are you
out there with microphone get Joe's
attention he will get you the microphone
and we'll we'll get some audience
questions here in a moment this
gentleman is not just an artist but a
bartender is that correct
his trader Vic trader Vic commercial and
in his latter days he was also a
sculptor a self-proclaimed sculptor and
here he is in his in the studio of his
instructor and it was the occasion was a
a wonderful luncheon that he gave for
herb King and Barney Conrad and and a
few really nifty ladies and and here was
this was the best sculpture that they
ever did
this was the my time and at one time he
called me on the phone said hey lion I
gotta set the record straight somebody
else said they invented the mai tai and
I invented the mai tai and you're gonna
do a series of pictures and they're
gonna run them in life because you were
the editor of life at that time no just
just hand I wrote a nice nice I couldn't
talk him out of it's like I called his
office and spoke to the his executive
the top executive I said I can't get
this thing in life this isn't the sort
of thing they run and he won't take no
for an answer to just don't argue with
the trader it's gotta cost him a lot of
money but just take the pictures and
they won't ever make them and it was
already alright because he said a truck
over that had
fishnets and not those kind of fishing
boats cases of rum cases of my tie a mix
a barrel of snow ice and that us very
small oriental Asian gentlemen who know
exactly how to put all these things
together when when that gentleman left
the studio I was left with all this but
it was it was a marvelous time it was a
time and I was going to spend the summer
in the Napa Valley and none of our
friends had a real a real home there and
I always appeared wherever we went for
whatever occasion with a little basket
with all my might I stuck in it I was a
riot
and I should say this is one of the few
photos here that Fred didn't take this
is probably before you were holding a
camera I would my early days I think
that was in hankie game yeah in Oakland
which was the predecessor but you did
take this cover photo for his
autobiography I think that bit later he
thinks as well so we're we're running a
little short on time I do want to get
another say I was telling the whole
story I'm oh I'm sorry
and what happened that my wife wants to
hear it what are you doing tomorrow all
right are you sure you're gonna tell
every chapter Oh God
I want to invoke another Bay Area icon
of photography of a different sort which
is Adolf gasser but but this starts this
story starts with a photo shoot that you
did of rice fields is that right fortune
wanted me to do a story on the rice
harvest up in the Sacramento Valley and
the rice harvest is not an easy thing to
dramatize it just didn't have it and I
thought what can I do that will be
special
so i conve a grower there to agree just
take three of his harvesters and start
them out together in a field but they
moved at different rates and once they
started out they were not going to come
back so this is like a Busby Berkeley
choreography of rice harvest but it's
all the rice is ready to harvest so you
only get one shot because then it
started to be hot and so I had I had
really just minutes to cover it I
decided it should be an aerial and I
needed a special aerial camera and so
this fellow on the left is the terrible
stubborn Swiss camera genius named Adolf
gasser
who who did miracles for all
professional photographers and had his
store on Second Street for forever until
why just last Kabir's and I'm Gary yes
right and and his son still lives in the
Bay Area everybody used him but he did
marvelous things and you knew him well
I'm building underwater
camera for me that was a huge terrifying
Plexiglas miracle and close to a like it
and it it had everything but we mustn't
discuss that but I said Adolph we need a
special aerial camera and so I described
the problem to him and he found an old
Graflex and took the back end of it
which had a a focal-plane shutter which
was a a miracle of cloth and springs and
levers and and he made a wooden comb for
it and and I had a war circle surplice
aerial lens and he would use that but it
he had had to be focusable at aerial
cameras had to be rigid and so the
lenses only focused at infinity but I
wanted to be in an in a crop duster
playing and I wanted to be down low and
so I said you we have to be able to
focus and he said well you can have one
focal point how far do you want that to
be I said let's make it a hundred feet
and so he created this terrible looking
camera is that is that this guy that's
in the photo I mean that I told you is
this guy but then yeah well what you're
holding is though I'm holding it's not
that camera this is another another one
of them another Frank Jeremiah NamUs
this we constructed for a certain for a
task
yeah for a task this is the world's
ugliest camera
but we put it together we put these
cameras together for a specific use and
then we were got it you know make the
finished version of course we never got
around to that but but we did a lot of
work with these cameras and they were
terrible but Adolph did did do this but
he built that camera overnight and he
and I were in his shop until far in the
night and the focusing depended upon a a
a spring-loaded race I can't describe
this except that it was dependent upon
three little ball bearings that were a
certain diameter and that would make the
other so I had I had two focal points I
had infinity and a hundred feet but to
get it 200 feet we had to have these
three ball bearings and in the middle of
the night when he was doing the final
assembly he dropped one of the ball
bearings and if you've ever seen two
grown men with flashlights tweezers
blowing across the floor inch by inch
you know everything we did there was
some crisis involved but so did you get
the shot I went the next day and I had
to edit and I'm sure super early in the
morning right oh yes yeah just after
John yeah and I was in the back seat a
crop-dusting plane which were biplanes
because they they had a lot of wing
space which was necessary for
for it crop-dusting but I was in the
back and I was faced backwards or I was
hanging out of but I wasn't able to
really watch em and when you were going
very quickly at a hundred feet over the
ground it's very important to get the
picture at the precise moment and that
was what I concentrated on but I recall
after the first pass I he then pulled
out to go around you and he looked at
back at me and said want to go again I
thought my stomach was going out through
the soles of my but we had to go around
again but we only had a couple of passes
and then they then that harvesters were
gone but it made it made a nice little
relief so we're gonna we're gonna get to
an audience question so chair if you've
got something cued up in in a second I
want to just I want to mention your
books really quickly and and another
amazing shy which you've never - let's
take our time
fred is free signing the books in the
back both these books and while we're
talking about them so so the noir book
just came out last year right right and
and the other one the San Francisco
portraits approach of a city just a few
years before that so and you're working
on another book right now is that
accurate
right so it's a restlessness I have yeah
yeah so you're drawing you're drawing
from work that you've that you've done
as these it
I'm not shooting much yeah you're not
going out after this and and go on
location I were yeah I actually I'd love
to do another San Francisco book but I
need another hundred years okay or
ninety-four you're a little bit ahead of
that pace so so this is another
incredible story I'm not sure forget to
tell it another amazing aerial shot that
you have on the cover of the portrait of
a city book but let's see Joe where are
you you've got a question great let's
hear that question
thank you hold it very close please
really helps yeah they've got you don't
worry okay yeah so I this has been
absolutely brilliant incredibly fabulous
and I hope that long now an interval
will take the opportunity to do an
archive with Fred Lyon and do part
two-part season even part four until we
hear this amazing amazing photographer
tell us every tiny detail about his
photographs
I'm a little worried about that archive
it sounds like I might be in a long box
No so what while you while you guys
continue ask questions I'm just gonna
flip through more of his photos so your
your questions may be interrupted by
who's and ahhs Joe do we have another
one you have it in someone else's hands
there or I need a mic if somebody's
there you are young man make sure to
hold it very close to your mouth so we
can hear it mr. Lyon
lovely photographs I can't even begin to
imagine the years of experience and
training that went into getting all that
technique oh I have more of an
historical question for you relating to
the jazz pictures you were taking can
you say anything about the those were in
the what the 40s and the 50s I guess ah
it was a lovely time and I have a
specific question could you say could
you say something about the color line
that used to exist between black and
white jazz musicians along Venice Avenue
back then well in the music world and
the music world the color line really
disappeared
everybody recent well it's like like the
photography world everybody respects
good work and there were times when herb
and I would be the only two white guys
in a club on Fillmore Street but we were
perfectly welcome there because
everybody was there for the music and
the music was so good I I was a great
fan of Dixie and
Dixey was having a resurgence in San
Francisco at that time and so I didn't
turn down any opportunities but it was
where everybody came to meet everybody
who was interested in the music and I'd
say music is one of the best Levellers
and places where we all enjoy one
another and you know there's just no
artery arguing with good music the scene
was great so Fred let's I'm gonna sneak
in a question here about the Golden Gate
Bridge I was showing some of the photos
but you have this amazing so so you you
got up in there well as as they say tell
tell us about what this was an
assignment I take it actually was fun it
was early on and I had to I had to keep
getting these assignments so some unwary
magazine said oh yeah go ahead and shoot
that and I went to the Golden Gate
Bridge office and said I'm a
photographer and this magazine wants to
do a story on the bridge painters and
they said oh yeah go out and see Joe
he's the foreman he'll fix you up
and so I I show was thought it was
really funny and I was crawling around
the bridge for a couple of weeks and
they oh they were all amused and after
you know they they saw me running around
and a couple of times they saved me from
doing dangerous
I must say there were vantage points
that I had you know photography is all
about getting your camera located the
proper viewpoint so that's what what I
was always about that's what made
aerials and even underwater necessary
but here for instance I was underneath
the roadbed which was really the
scariest place that little thing in the
center is Alcatraz and when you're
beneath the roadbed there is a very odd
sensation because you cannot see the
usually cannot see the horizon so you
look down and if there's a breeze you
see Whitecaps moving underneath you and
the sensation is that the ridge is
falling over it's very very that that's
that is much scarier than being up on
top being up on top is achieved by there
is in each tower there is a tiny
electric elevator and it will
accommodate two painters and if they
hold their lunch bucket on their top of
their head and it goes fairly slowly up
at the top they've also discovered that
you can get two more guys on top of the
cage if you remember to stop the
elevator and time
otherwise our thoughts are good but the
first time I got up on top I was so
excited that I ran out and started to
run down a cable and well like I said I
buddy I think you better come back here
I want to give you a safety belt and I
really appreciated your concern well
well we're about to have to wrap this up
I'm afraid I want it I'm gonna actually
introduce one squeak one last thing in
here Fred's gonna hang out and and we'd
love for you to come up and and see them
and say hi if you if you've got a energy
to hang out with this a few more minutes
I want to just touch on this thing we'll
just do it quickly this is almost a
moment of science fiction with San
Francisco a future that never was so
this is what we we talked about this is
the the potential design for highways of
San Francisco and again another
illustration from map from David Rumsey
z-- map collection this is the 50 I
don't know if I remember the the year on
this but tell us something about this
because use a great opportunity missed
it was just terrifying 48 48 yeah so so
this is a close-up so was it was so we
know about the Embarcadero Freeway as
you mentioned it earlier but these were
freeways kind of all over the city well
they were for instance the one I was
concerned with because I lived in
Sausalito at that time I was concerned
with this connection to the freeway
system from the Golden Gate Bridge
because there were a lot of people who
didn't want to be strained through the
whole traffic of the city they wanted to
be on the other side they perhaps were
going to the airport and there were it
was highly contentious because what we
ran up against were eventually was some
politicians who
real estate that might be impinged upon
when they did wonderful free freeways
expressways through the city but that's
what what this marvelous map was and I
hadn't seen this map for so long I had
forgotten a lot and it all it even shows
a southern crossing which is something
that still needs to be done and you came
up with a marvelous illustration well
and this is the light so this would have
been a tunnel under Russian Hill I I
would not like to some things better not
to fool with well I'm gonna flip through
a few more of these photos we have a lot
more amazing Fred Lyon work we'd love
for you to stick around come say hi to
Fred please buy his books in the back
Fred this has been amazing as this been
amazing
[Applause]
like I can't believe I can't believe
that I have have cornered so many good
people by a space you can unlock the
door now Fred and a great deal of fun
for this a little thank-you gift from us
it's the long now challenge coin it's
for you
it has our motto on a car payment the
Millennium and a thousands of years old
Bristlecone pine on the other side so
thank you for your incredible work we're
saying this time with us thank all of
you for coming out and let's hang out
we've got some more cocktails thanks to
the cocktail thank you
[Music]